(horns honking)
(crowd chattering)
- [Jared] Turkey is headed to
a runoff election on May 28th.
(Recep speaking in foreign language)
(Kemal speaking in foreign language)
- What happens in this election
will have enormous stakes,
both for Turkey and for
the rest of the world.
Turkey is a member of
NATO, a member of the G20,
one of the world's largest economies.
It's also a country that has
a central geopolitical role
in the Middle East,
and in the war between Russia and Ukraine.
Erdogan is one of the only world leaders
who speaks regularly
with Russia's president, Vladimir Putin,
making him an important
channel into the Kremlin.
President Erdogan is facing a number
of challenges to his reelection.
Turkey has been in a currency crisis
over the last two plus years
in part due to his own economic decisions
in which he has pressured the central bank
into cutting interest rates
in spite of Turkey's
high rate of inflation.
It's caused living standards to unravel.
The rising costs of food, of housing,
of medicine has really
narrowed Erdogan's power base
and turned some people who used
to vote for him against him.
Another challenge is
the devastation caused
by the earthquakes that shook
Turkey and Syria in February.
It killed more than 56,000 people.
People living in the earthquake zone said
that they were basically left alone
and that state institutions,
including the emergency
services, the police
and the army were slow to
arrive, leaving thousands
of people underneath the
rubble waiting to be rescued.
(Mehmet speaking in foreign language)
On the other hand,
Kemal Kilicdaroglu is
the long-serving leader
of Turkey's largest opposition party,
the Republican People's Party.
If Kilicdaroglu wins, it
would be a historic victory
for Turkey's opposition and
it would really breathe life
into democratic
institutions here in Turkey.
He's been a fixture in
Turkish politics for decades.
He has been leading the Turkish opposition
over the last decade.
His profile as a kind
of elder statesman positions
himself as anti-Erdogan.
He likes to say that he doesn't
use polarizing language.
At the same time, he's promising
to accelerate Turkey's clamp down
on immigrants promising to push millions
of Syrian and Afghan
refugees out of the country.
Over the last 20 years,
Erdogan has made himself
into Turkey's most powerful
leader in a century.
And if he's brought down
through Democratic means,
that could inspire hope
that other countries could do the same.
(pensive music)